comment ne pas penser quand même que le
petit fils de simone signoret qui a
lundi sur les genoux d'yves montand est
le fils de laurent fabius pion qui a
grandi sur ses genoux qui a grandi sur
les genoux entre 1 12 mai qui a vu
défiler à la maison qui a vu défiler à
la maison le gratin d'une époque donc de
gens engagés en politique nous trouvé
rien de mieux à l'âge que vous avez de
faire de laisser la télé people j'ai 25
ans a voulu 45 ans je me dis je me crame
je me crame rai due to 25 ans révolus
que tu sois reporter envoyé spécial à 25
ans à signaler quand tu dis si tu vois
créé un mur donc une opportunité
sympathique de faire un truc qui te
permet de découvrir deux côtés des
choses futiles mais c'est peut-être
aussi ce dont j'avais besoin de
futilités ce n'est que j'ai pas fait
d'études j'ai arrêté mes études à 17 ans
j'ai commencé à la plonge dans groupe
accor après je de room service après
j'étais femme de chambre après j'étais
directeur d'hôtel après
les jeunes notamment dirigé le texan
avant le fils de fab us à diriger un
hôtel à bagnolet à 600 chambres de six
ans soit 20 ans ensuite j'ai monté ma
première boîte à 21 ans j'ai eu deux
cents employés
vers des duvets tu voulais bien être un
mec
0 2 mais j'ai une impression de gâchis
non mais non mais gâchis on se gâche
quand on fait pas ce qui nous donne du
plaisir et la satisfaction moi j'ai
beaucoup de plaisir à faire cette
émission est temps que j'en aurais je la
ferai quand je n'aurai plus bas niveau
en dix ans et coûté une place de piger
dans tes émissions voulais tu me diras
matière [ __ ]
tu veux absolument mettre en opposition
le fait que je fasse de la télé people
et le fait que j'ai un père qui était
premier ministre s'est pas antinomiques
c'est comme les gens qui lisent ou alors
vous êtes de gauche si vous êtes riche
non c'est pousser ça reste un problème
paris n'en fait pas tout si ça reste un
problème non non non et que son compère
il en pense que c'est comme avant d'être
premier ministre les pères et s'ils
seront fils est heureux ce qui est le
cas il y revit les blocs où il est on
est on à moi je suis très féminin non
mais son père l'a d'orge et est donc
voilà mais si tu
veux convaincre mon père qui doit avoir
honte de moi je te laisse la plaie au
noir je n'avais pas c'est un autre frère
qu'est ce qui fait victorieuse il est
fait normal sans ce pôle sorbonne assas
columbia et prépare ménard voilà bien
lui il est dans la vie tu
admires qu'un homme son frère
faudrait pas que tu as l'impression que
tu as grèce 1 mais allongera
presque au bout ça fasse mal gré sport
non mais je vois là
parcours fait que tout explose à ce
genre de questions c'était très
courageux d'aller dans ce sens là alors
que ça devrait nous rapporter quand même
une famille comme ça je pense qu'on peut
quand même chance et lors de ses rêves
un petit de 25 ans dû poser la question
du champ ce qui donne à sa vie rien
voilà c'est tout on peut être cynique à
40 mais à 25 pour moi on est irréaliste
géocaching mais
avec senna qu'est ce que la montagne et
moi j'étais reporter je voulais faire
des sujets sur sur l'humanitaire sur les
pauvres sur les choses qui me
paraissaient plus vrai que sincère que
que sakho et puis même aujourd'hui à 40
berges je ferais jamais ça va plutôt
crever que que racontait la vie des
stars c'est voilà c'est le pas hier
plutôt crever 6 et c'est bien parce que
chris est pavé le sait plus faire
quelque chose non elle a réussi en une
seule manière bien c'est que c'est le
côté gâchis aussi quoi de dieu quand
même tapis et a eu une chance dans la
vie qui est supérieur aux autres tout en
faisant autre chose que que valoriser
ces manifestants liberty sim fait rien
c'est qu'il ya un nivellement des
activités faire que via le baiia le
panier qui est le people il ya le walkie
et le culturel est arrivé si tu permets
à des gens de rêver en faisant les
people figure
du père c'était les gens maintenant je
je je tue moi je là je suis d'accord
avec christophe sûr qu'à un moment entre
s'occuper de la vie de loana et de
platon comme le fait notre amie rachel
mais pourtant je suis pas d'une famille
mais comment tu as connu platon alors
nommé dans un karaoké savait malade est
magnifique moi je connaissais pas
j'habite il avait dit jeudi à priori oui
mais maintenant je vais avoir
tout j'ai pas trouvé bien moi je trouve
que pour une fois et physique un petit
peu particuliers et est ravissant et et
ça c'est bien ce qui s'est passé qu'elle
n'a pas le nez la retrousse le match
semble banal à la vraie photo je vais
pas trouver bien et j'aime bien ta ta ta
ta nouvelle mission comme platon dans
les matchs de gueule
maintenant je dis non seulement aller
vers un lycée mongy d'élégance c'est mon
job j'attaque un peu bien en tête mais
parce que toute façon il faut aller à
l'essentiel si on tourne autour du
pauvre et voilà ça pour moi ça reste une
interrogation et du jour où j'ai vu que
tu faisais cette émission je connais pas
ce gars là je t'avais judo deux fois
parlé de ses crèches que tu as été un
petit peu invité à la télé pour parler
de tes crèche d'entreprise m'étais dit
qu'un là il ya une filiation en a il
s'est lancé dans quelque chose qui est à
la fois sociales à l'époque conférait
les boîtes et à l'époque ton père était
de centre gauche il y avait une logique
tiens voilà le fils de fabius il a créé
toujours ressemble à ses parents je veux
lire hp pour les gens qui s'occupent des
enfants à toi non non non non la radio
non non mais attends la chieuse parce
qu'il a un père communiste colombie
c'est une question de sens pourquoi
mais on va crever pas donner de sens à
nos vies les alpha et le renaissance qui
voit là mais voudrait donner son sens à
ma vie
les clous on est sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu